remember when they had the situation
maybe two years ago
where they weren't producing the the
model the e
or whatever and he had to go in there
and sleep on the couch and work 20 hours
a day
for like a month and a half to keep it
going i mean he basically saved the
company right there yeah
so it's it's a tug of war because he's
right and he is going to lose some good
executives along the way but i don't
know don't you think that he thinks
if i lost tesla i'll just go build
another one but but but here's a saying
buddy like this is this is how i
again listen elon musk's elon musk i
admire this man for what he's done and
god knows he's done more good for the
world than bad so we need
we we have to keep a guy like this same
to keep producing and solving many big
problems
because he vibrates at a level other
people don't but this is the one part to
keep in mind
when you're good talk about it
promote it yeah if you're good at
something but when you're great you
don't talk about it other people do yeah
other people do you michael jordan never
went around talking about how great he
is
lebron either lebron has a different
story but michael jordan just went and
showed you greatness and then you said
this man is great elon musk is great
you don't need to tell us we know
already are great all right how about
you just said something you got to keep
him got to keep himself sane
he's going in there he's working 18-hour
days he says he only works he only
sleeps four hours how long can you keep
that up before there's burnout
how long i like just because you're an
executive doesn't mean you're not a
human and that's just kind of
there has to be like we expect these
people to function at such a high level
you got a ferrari best car in the world
you keep it in the red for too long the
engine expects
i don't disagree but here's what happens
just so you know what happens if you're
redlining it too much you know what
happens
happened to me a handful of times in my
career when i'm when i'm pushing too
hard and again this
scares the hell out of some people when
i'm pushing too hard my body just shuts
down
you go to the emergency room you get
ived up and people tell you know your
your body's purely on exhaustion one
time i was on a two-week
road trip visiting all these offices and
i was going on two to four hours of
sleep a night
it was just you know very difficult to
when i came back
on two o'clock in the morning i don't
even know what's going on my body i went
to the hospital
and next thing you know they checked me
out they put the iv in me they said sir
i said is it my heart
it says no your heart is fine
everything's functioning well your
body's just telling you are freaking
exhausted is what it is this happens to
athletes who are pushing the limits this
happens to military this happens to
business people
and he's testing by the way eventually
something's going to happen to his
health
and that's what gets them like you know
when a lot of these people
business people they hit a wall and then
there's a health issue and they're like
i better start paying attention to it
he's going to pay attention to it as
well
but i think for him you're not going to
slow him down like is someone going to
sit this guy down and say
hey hilar i think you need to get seven
hours of sleep to reach rem he ain't
going to listen to nobody now if you
don't even think it's that though
i'm talking about like when i get tired
you know i my
patience is the first thing that goes
and this might be something tweeting two
o'clock in the morning after 48 hours of
work and where he just doesn't have
patience
he just doesn't have the patience you
know what i'm saying for me when i get
when i get worn down you get the
physical that you're talking about but
the mental drain is even worse where i
just i don't have the patience for
something
small that i would have been able to be
like all right no worries about it we'll
talk about it tomorrow
when i was functioning at a level i
should be functioning at 11 hours later
i'm just like dude why would you even
ask me something so stupid like you snap
at something like that the patience goes
i think if you read between these lines
with his quotes too i think he feels
trapped
because he's built i don't disagree yeah
i think he's built such a behemoth he
wishes he had that exit button he knows
he can't leave he knows that come
he hey it's physically impossible for
him to leave that company
but if he could and that's why he's
doing saturday night live and that's why
he's going over to richard branson's
you know cheap kitchen the night of his
flight by the way there's some great
memes with
with musk and branson in that kitchen
together but he would he would exit
stage left if he could i i don't i don't
disagree
with that as well listen sometimes
remember the last dance when michael's
going through his back to back to back
then his father then the whole thing is
just like i just want to get away
guy would be in a hotel remember that
one scene we're just sitting in the
whole term just waiting for the game
just doesn't look happy you look
miserable like you're like you wanted
this your entire life now
but dennis rodman i need three days in
vegas
he had to come back he had to come back
and figure out a way how to deal with
media and do it in a way where it worked
for him the second time around if you
ever watch michael first time around
media
second time around media it's as if that
year and a half got him
to straighten out his relationship with
the media and he learn how to deal with
them i think elon's got to you know step
away yeah
i think he's got a maybe six month
hiatus you just gotta go away bro just
go do your thing spend some time with
your kids with your wife with whatever
you want to do
keep it low keep figure yourself i can
come back out because the way he's going
right now
i i think he's going to they're not
going to let him go at the pace he's
going right now they're just not
he's going to show up and he's got two
other big companies that he's trying to
run as well like if he takes some time
away from tesla he still has you know
the the rocket company and then he still
got his solar company and then he still
has his boring company and
trying to save the world he's a rock
star man you know he's a he's the kind
of guy
that a thousand years from now if we
don't have armageddon happen with
dinosaurs showing back up people are
going to read about elon musk and
elon musk is going to be a rockefeller
chase type of a guy he's a
once-in-a-lifetime generation type of
guy we gotta
appreciate the guy when he's here so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye